non
on a aujourd'hui on en parle beaucoup en
ce moment le problème des femmes comment
expliquer qu'à notre époque encore le
salaire des femmes soit inférieur à
celui des hommes vous évoquez à juste
titre
principes républicains que je suis très
attaché l'égalité des droits l'égalité
des chances ce principe ne s'applique
pas aux femmes c'est étonnant mais c'est
s et je dirais dans la complicité
général
alors il ya d'abord l'égalité des droits
on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui
à travail égal et contrairement à ce que
exige la loi la femme gagne en gros 30 %
de moins que là
ce n'est pas admissible
deuxièmement il ya l'égalité des chances
lorsqu'on regarde les postes de
direction dans l'ensemble des
entreprises privées ou publiques on
s'aperçoit que le pourcentage de femmes
est très faible par rapport aux autres
choses dans quelques carrières
particulière donc l'égalité des chances
n'est pas non plus reconnu comment faire
je vois que nous avons aujourd'hui des
syndicats ouvriers
patronat nouveau qui aborde les choses
me semble-t-il avec beaucoup plus de
dynamisme et de réalisme que ce ne fut
le cas dans le passé et je propose que
parmi les grands sujets de société
il doit y avoir le rôle la place les
droits des femmes à l'égalité des droits
à l'égalité des chances
c'est un des objets d'une grande
concertation entre les partenaires
sociaux puis deuxièmement il ya problème
politique
les femmes ont droit depuis 50 ans et
nous sommes aujourd'hui le pays
européens
de tous où le nombre de femmes élues et
le plus faire lors de 5 à 6% pour ce qui
concerne le parlement ce n'est pas
acceptable
alors prenez votre liberté et fait en
sorte que la parité soit
sinon une réalité total au moins qu'on
en soit aussi proche que possible dans
les listes municipales ça créera déjà un
choc et ce sera premier pas important et
poneys
la famille pilier fondamental la
structure notre société qu'est ce qu'on
fait pour que la famille soit mieux
équilibrée plus épanouie et puis se fait
en sorte que chacun trouve sa place
dignement doit il faut bien comprendre
qu'une
collectivité
corps social
c'est comme un corps humain docteur
ces composés de cellules
et quand les cellules dépérissent c'est
le corps tout entier qui dès lors la
famille est le premier rempart la
première sécurité sociale
à l'égard de sel ou de ceux qui sont
touchés wattin par la vie et qui
pourraient devenir des exclus il est
donc essentiel d'avoir une relance forte
de la politique familiale
à
on croyait pas qu'il est aussi un
problème d'école ont l'impression que
l'école est plus fait pour les parents
pour les enseignants que pour les
enfants oui moi je crois que la réforme
des rythmes scolaires est une nécessité
elle est nécessaire pour je dirais les
plus fragiles de nos enfants ceux qui
sont issus des milieux les plus modestes
et qui n'ont pas l'environnement qui
compense les inconvénients que vous
venez de souligner et qui n'ont pas
normalement et facilement accès à la
culture ou d'ailleurs au sport est donc
l'objectif doit être d'abord à l'école
puis au collège puis au lycée est de
faire en sorte que les disciplines de la
connaissance traditionnelle
soit donné le matin et que l'après midi
soit consacrée à la fois aux disciplines
du corps sportives et à celle de la
culture soit ce que chacun est aussi
accès à la culture